okay here you go brother it's you hi
brother God bless you Lord bless you too
what's going on I have two questions
brother sorry I'll try to answer one of
them is from my son why are you so upset
man it's like your said hi brother I'm
no no I I literally had no answer for
him so I was like I tried to give him I
tried to give him some answer but it
didn't make sense in today's world
Leviticus 20 verse number n how can God
be this
well I don't know what he means how can
God be this cruel why can you read the
verse so people can understand what
you're asking if there is anyone who
curses his father or his mother he shall
surely be put to death he has cursed his
father or his mother his blood
guiltiness is upon him yeah so if God is
loving and he forgives why can't father
or mother be forgiving as well why a son
has to be put to death well that's not
only Leviticus 20:9 let me make it
harder for your son are you ready yes
sir that's what I want make it harder go
to Deuteronomy 21 18 to 24 yep
18 you got that yes sir all right so
what does it say read Deuteronomy 21 18
21 if a man has a stubborn and
rebellious son who will not obey the
voice of his father or the voice of his
mother and who when they have chastened
him ch they've rebuked them to repent
will not heed them then his father and
his mother shall take hold of him and
bring him out to the Elders of the city
to the gates of the city and they shall
say to the Elder of this city the son of
our is stubborn all right sorry so we
read Deuteronomy 218 to 20 keep reading
sorry yeah 21 21 is the important verse
then all the men of his City shall Stone
him to death with stones so you shall
put away the evil from among you and all
the Israel shall hear and fear yes you
put the evil among you why why is God
having him cut off it's not that God is
cruel if he's been given enough time to
repent and turn but he refuses and he
keeps disrespecting dishonoring his
parents it would be an act of Injustice
to allow such a man to be a burden on a
parents and to oppress his parents It's
actually an act of Mercy for the parents
that someone who's so rebellious and
hardened and opposes them and opposes
God in doing so because he knows the
rule of God such evil has to be cut off
before it spreads and corrupt
Society so how is it cruel when it's
protecting parents from
oppressive tyrants children who are
tyrants who are burdened who make the
life of parents hell no matter how many
times they're told repent because then
they're doing it willfully def ly and
they're not just defying their parents
they're defying God who warned them and
therefore an example needs to be made
out of them so that others will fear and
not act corruptly and then corrupt
society which is what you're finding
today with teenagers who don't get
discipline what are they doing to
society pretty bad so how is this cruel
when it's an act of Mercy to the parents
and teaching others lesson if you think
you can be oppressive and tyrannical and
oppress your parents and harm your
parents and be a burden to your parents
and not repent then you have a thing
coming because you know better because
God told you honor them and you've been
warned but you refuse now you need to be
cut off from the land lest you keep
oppressing them and burning them which
would be cruelty for
them but when you remove that oppression
it's now Mercy for them because notice
it got to the point they reported him to
the judges meaning they're fed up with
him
true then did you understand who brought
the rebellious son to the judges the
parents that means the parents have
reached a Breaking Point they can't
handle him
anymore that his oppression is too much
for them to
tolerate and they need help because they
can't constrain him for a parent to get
to that point to hand you over to the
judges to be punished that means you
must be so oppressive and rebellious
that they hate their life because of you
so it would be cruelty to allow them to
endure that oppression it's Mercy for
the parents to remove this cancer and
then teach others to fear the lord this
will happen to you if you do not act
right so in today's world if I will
translate it so the moment when a parent
is willing
to call in the police on their son that
kind of level yes it's that kind of a
level because notice if the parents take
their son to the judges they know
they're asking does is to put him to
death what level must you reach to be so
fed up with your child you're wishing
that he'd be dead then
alive pretty high so that's why if you
read the Bible in context this is Mercy
for the parents so you want the parents
who in their old age can't constrain him
to continue to live under his oppression
and misery as he terrorizes
them that makes sense yeah it it depends
you know the kids nowadays bring up so
many okay I'm I'm not here to convince
kids what I'm saying is this is the
wisdom behind God showing Mercy to
parents who have an unruly son who's
making their life hell and miserable and
he's being a terrorist terrorizing them
and they're so sick of their life
because of him that they now reach the
breaking point bring him to the judges
meaning for them to get to that point
because they know he's going to be
killed that means that's how evil and
rebellious unruly is they're sick of him
and living with him you got to get to a
Breaking Point to get it to that level
for sure for sure having kids I I do
realize that to go to that level is
almost impossible yes and sadly there
have been children who will push parents
to that level because of their evil
their oppression their tyranny being
like a terrorist and destroying their
lives robbing them you know like drug
addicts if they're addicted robbing
their parents beating their parents to
get them to give money to support their
habit that happens a lot that's I'm not
just it's not the arod that happens
their children who get to the point of
addiction they end up going and beating
up their parents to steal their money or
steal their property and Rob
them they're living in hell and misery
and because there is no check in
Balance they go and do it and Corruption
spreads in society which is why we got
so much evil
so much tyranny in America today as we
speak you get my point yeah so why is
God saying read the last part again you
read Deuteronomy 21821 read 21 again 21
again yeah some even killed their
parents exactly you want to get to that
point like our sister said so if you
understand God's wisdom this is actually
Mercy for the parents and what they call
a deterrent fear for others look here's
an example you do this you'll end up
dead so to constrain the evil Hearts
from acting on their evil this is God's
way of controlling the evil in your
heart so you don't go crazy and ruly and
spread evil because until you're born of
the spirit until the spirit captures
your heart you're prone to Evil And You
See It in America people are afraid to
go to some cities because they're afraid
they're going to get robbed and killed
and you see the drug addiction and the
homelessness because this is what
happens when you abandon God's Rule and
you think you're more compassionate than
God and no better all hell breaks loose
on a
society L 2121 again 21 again then all
the men of his City shall Stone him to
death with stones so you shall put away
the evil from among you and all Israel
shall hear and fear do you see why when
Israel sees this Bo man he's not a Boy
by the way killed they will be afraid
and think twice isn't it true let's use
Islam as an example and sadly have to
use Islam because people in Saudi Arabia
will have their hand chopped off if they
steal isn't it true that you don't have
high crime in Sai Arabia people stealing
because of
that in Muslim countries like just
generally not even Saudi Arabia where
you came from how many people would dare
to steal if there was Islamic law
implemented your hand gets cut off
yeah it will be difficult uh but at the
same time there is they will they will
cut the hands of a 12 years old as well
I'm talking about because of the fear of
having your hand cut off has that
decreased
stealing yeah probably yeah probably how
many people you know got in Pakistan
stole and got away with it Pakistan they
don't cut the hand so there is a lot of
stealing over there forget Pakistan
sorry that's why see you okay that's why
I use Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia they'll
cut your hand off because they try to
follow Sharia for now anyway that's why
I use that example okay Einstein don't
make it more harder for me before I
shave your head get the point yeah I got
the point in a Muslim land that Sharia
compliant and they know they'll cut your
hand off will that decrease the amount
of stealing yep y okay that's what I'm
trying to show you I'm not saying Sharia
is like the old testament old testament
is superior to Sharia but I'm giving you
a principle when people know that if you
do something you'll be punished that
puts the fear of God in them to
constrain them from doing it this is
what God is saying here I don't want my
people to run a monk and do what is
right in their sight and then create
chaos where they harm the innocent
oppress the helpless who can't defend
themselves and kill one another so
here's how you're going to do it until
they get saved because until you're born
of the spirit until you're born of the
spirit yep you have evil that you act on
here people who before they came to
Christ in America teenagers young adults
doing drugs getting drunk having sex
before marriage abortion until if they
do turn to Christ get convicted and stop
now because of the spirit they don't do
it anymore because of the love for
Christ so what God is saying what do you
do to people before they receive the
spirit or born of the spirit and love
the Lord how do you constrain them you
teach them if we catch you doing this
you will be put to
death got it yep if I were living in the
Old Testament do you think my ex-wife
would commit
adultery probably most likely not you
better believe not she would have got
stone with the the dogs that she commit
adultery with if we were living in a
Muslim country you think these women
like my would commit adultery I'd commit
adultery if the Sharia is implementing
no this is the wisdom of God giving you
that I showed you that in 1 Timothy
chapter 1 5-10 did you remember that the
law is given for
evildoers yes to constrain their evil to
teach them the fear that if you act on
your evil you will be removed from the
land of the living until when you're
born in Sp that's why Paul says the laws
for evil doers not for us what do you
mean for us because we who love the Lord
because of we don't they're here like
what's stopping me from going and having
sex with multiple women Jesus
I can go right now find someone to have
sex the law won't condemn me the law
won't punish me so what's stopping me
because I don't want to break Jesus's
heart I want to love him I don't love
him enough it's the love of Jesus that
says to me no don't do
that but love of Jesus what do I do to
constrain people from being from
having sex before marriage and then when
they get pregnant murdering the child
well that's why you had the old testment
system but when you don't follow that
kind of system that's why you you have
now adultery going out of style
fornication like it's no in fact
multiple partners and one proof of it I
recommend everyone watch paternity court
it's on YouTube it is the most
heartbreaking series it's an actual
judge who has to give DNA tests to
actual people prity court because they
don't know who the father is because
they've slept with so many
men and then you see the Heartbreak of
the children grown women saying I don't
know who my father is because my mother
had sex with multiple people and she
doesn't know who my father is that's the
society you produce without the law
saying hey you have sex before marriage
you're going to marry that person no
divorce or if you commit adultery you'll
be put to death and be
killed and that then
lessens reduces the evil of Hearts the
the hearts of men until they're born of
spirit Now in America you can commit
adultery and I want to be labor I'm
trying to hammer this point you can have
multiple sexual partners no one's going
to condemn you but why don't we do
it because why don't we try to be a
player in a jiggalo and go on these
sites and find multiple women have sex
with them because the Law's not going to
punish me because I want to love Jesus
and honor him I don't love him enough
and I don't want to do that it's not
because I'm afraid I'll be killed no
one's going to kill me meaning the law
but it will break Jesus's heart and it's
not even the fear of judgment it's I
don't want to break his heart so coming
back to the issue Deuteronomy 21:21 says
why this needs to be done when you put
an unruly son who has been such a terror
to his parents to death because now
they're at the point they despair of
life and they'd rather have him dead
than alive that will send a message to
other children this will happen to you
you better fear and honor your parents
there you go no thank you so very much
this side discussion will all also going
to help me a lot so I appreciate it yes
and connecting it to 1 Timothy chapter
number 21 1213 was also one verse not
yeah it was it was also very very very
great so yeah thank you thank you that's
cruelty tell him son hold on let's read
it isn't this Mercy for the parents who
are being abused and
terrorized against a child that's too
strong for them to resist no I I got it
I got it and secondly because like the
things that you brought brought up is
very important because when I was a
Muslim SL just left Islam it was for me
very difficult to comprehend that when
you have a Salvation in believing Christ
what is stopping you for committing sin
because you do not have punishment so
for me to comprehend this basic Point
took a long time so I I this is my own
testimony that it took me a long time to
comprehend because coming from Islam
everything has a punishment attached to
it and everything can get you to hell
for a certain period of time and hence
for me it was really really difficult to
comprehend hey you already have a
Salvation what's stopping you to do any
sin right so and yeah so it took yeah I
I I I got it yeah I want you to read
read 2 Corinthians 5:1 14- 16 for me pay
attention to verse 14 2 Corinthians 5:1
14- 16 so you get it now you understand
the logic the wisdom see if you take a
step of faith and say Lord You're
infinitely wiser than me I cannot
comprehend your infinite mind I'm wi I'm
weak Wicked imperfect limited so I'm
going to trust your wisdom that there is
something good in these commands and if
you walk by faith then he'll reward you
by opening your mind and then you're
going to say oh wow now I see but if you
come already thinking you know better
than God or questioning these commands
from God then he hands you over all
right believe what you
want got it got it now watch this this
principle that once you're born of the
spirit and you submit to the spirit your
love for Jesus is what hinders you
that's why when you do sin as a
Christian you're
broken you're broken why did I hurt you
Lord please forgive me Lord I'm weak
second Corinthians 514 to 16 notice
verse 14 I'm gonna go off
camera for the love of Christ compels us
that's
it what compels me what forces me not to
sin and do the things I I do the love of
Christ not the fear of God's Wrath not
God's judgment and threats because Jesus
Loves Me with an infinite love and so
perfectly his love melts me and makes me
do his
will did you catch it yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely right there so we
read it one more time brother for the
love of Christ compels us because we
judge
thus that if one die
for all then all died see keep reading
absolutely and he died for all that
those who live should live no longer for
themselves but for him who died for them
are rose again you see the beauty his
love compels me and makes me want to die
to myself in the world because he loved
me so much to die for me that love is so
so great it melts me and breaks me and
makes me want to die to myself in the
world and live for
him makes sense makes perfect sense
that's the difference between someone
who's not born from above and in love
with him and someone who is someone
who's not needs threats you you murder
you'll be put to death you steal you're
going to be thrown in jail you commit
adultery you'll be put to death once
you're born a spirit you don't need
those threats anymore